- Gary's about to give $1,400 to someone
to go to a Knick game and
sit courtside with them.
(suspenseful music)
(cheering)
- You've got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
(techno music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(smooth music)
(hiphop-RnB music)
It's all the same game.
Who can ever get closest to the customer
then once you have it,
then the ultimate thing's
gonna play out on voice.
This is not like things
are gonna happen on voice.
Alexa, I need this.
Who the hell wants to look
something up on Google?
That's why MetLife rents Snoopy.
That's why Chase pays Serena Williams
or buys the naming rights to
the new Warrior's stadium.
When you get real big you,
can afford to do these things
that make you top of the funnel.
It's worth the risk.
It's like in buying insurance.
Everybody as a human
has insurance right now,
highly unlikely you're
gonna use most of it
but nobody does the same
thing for their businesses.
Does brand, right?
The gray, not the black and white.
Everyone's in sales.
Every leader, she or he has to
reverse engineer themselves.
So for example, some people
look for DNA that are,
I need a killer and she's gonna sell
and we're a boiler plate
Wall Street fucking
and I'm that and you're that
and that's what I'm looking for.
And that person, she's spitting
on people in the phone group
to get them to sell more and
that fucking leader loves that.
I'd fire her.
So the answer to your question is
you need to know what you're about
from an EQ, IQ, money,
longterm continuity.
I'd much rather have a B
who wants to be here for 7 1/2 years
than a super A that wants
to be here for 14 months.
This is about ideas and making.
Right?
This is eliminating
subjectiveness and meetings
and things of that nature at the end
which is why we went with
the literal naming of it,
the volume of content is the biggest need
for anybody that wants to communicate,
whether you're a PTA member
trying to raise money
or the biggest brand in the world.
The volume of content
contextual to the distribution
with a result on the
backend of it is the model
and whoever gets there first and best
will disproportionately be successful
in the communications landscape
which is why we have embarked on this.
(smooth music)
Here we go!
Madison Square Garden, me and you.
The winner.
I love this Jets bag.
The winner of the Knicks,
Wolves sit-down session
from Barstool's Podcast is...
(smooth msuic)
Matt Calderon from?
- Matt Calderon from NYC.
- Phew!
Matt, looking forward to it.
"Grew up watching the
Knicks with my mother
"who is a lifelong fan
because of her father.
"Lost my mom to cancer in 2012
"but shared many great
Knick moments with her
"when they were good in the '90s.
"Waiting for them to be good again.
"Take me."
I'm taking you Matt, I'm taking you.
Awesome.
(smooth music)
- [Inquirer] So basically this morning,
we were gonna film but
you weren't in the mood
and you talked to people about
when they're doing a personal brand
and if they're not on,
don't worry about it,
don't judge yourself.
Can I just do that?
- Yeah, I think it's always
a bad time to force stuff
so when you wanted to film me
but I had things on my mind
that I knew I had to
communicate to employees
or I don't even remember.
We'll see the footage.
When I watch the blog I'll know.
Yeah, I mean, forcing
it never makes sense.
Caleb wants content, that's his job
and I'm 98% of the time super there
but I just couldn't get there.
I really had to address the issues at hand
and when you're not feeling
it, you're not feeling it.
Obviously, you wanna be
honest whenever you can.
You wanna perform when you have to
but especially when you're
vlogging or making content,
there's always tomorrow.
Those always six hours from now,
there's always right
now where I do feel it
and I wanna explain to you,
and this is where
Caleb's doing a good job.
You haven't seen that too
often but it's a truth.
Truth is I have shit on my
mind that I had to address
and I need to be really focused
and this is very passive to me
that's why I can always be miked
but at that moment, I was
like yeah, just not now.
And that's okay because
almost everything's okay.
Stop judging yourself.
(smooth music)
Hey guys, thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to Empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three-pack,
whether it's a six-pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me,
I could really use your support.